est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas là dedans fip et brûle
c'est à dire le rapport entre la
population territoire des porteurs de
causalité une explication mais des
densités un train sur dix appartements
il ya des chaînes de contagion du retour
à l'intérieur probablement dit milieu
familial parce qu on a des familles qui
vivent à trois générations et c'est tout
cet ensemble de causes qui constitue
finalement un syndrome en quelque sorte
social et dont le gaullisme est à la
fois le révélateur est malheureusement
la cause déterminante ponctuelles je
suis très frappé entre eux présentant
des sciences sociales par finalement le
progrès considérables comme apple en
tête tant d'ennemis qu'avant dérivation
attaque les mauvais côtés en un an on a
mis au point pratiquement
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 16 décembre
premières vaccinations contre le coc
vide 19 dès la dernière semaine de
décembre mais pas avant la fin du
printemps pour la population non
prioritaires jean castex a dévoilé cet
après midi la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement en promettant la
transparence pour susciter la confiance
l'agencé européenne du médicament
pourrait donner son feu vert dès lundi
prochain au vaccin développé par pfizer
bio n tech
si la france entame une nouvelle phase
avec le couvre-feu ailleurs en europe
les mesures se durcissent l'allemagne
entame ainsi aujourd'hui son premier
jour de confinement les néerlandais sont
confinés depuis hier jusqu'au 19 janvier
quant à la belgique après une phase de
stabilisation a bien le nombre moyen
d'infection quotidienne au corona virus
continue d'augmenter ces derniers jours
[Musique]
outre atlantique la campagne vaccinale
pas son plein joe biden se dit prêt à se
faire vacciner en public
les etats unis qui ont autorisé la
commercialisation du premier test
robuste 19 à domicile et sans ordonnance
côté politique le président élu biden
est en géorgie pour soutenir avec
candidat démocrate dans deux élections
sénatoriales cruciales pour pouvoir
mettre en place ces réformes nous serons
en direct des états unis
[Musique]
jean castex passé cet après midi
l'épreuve de l'assemblée nationale et a
détaillé devant les députés
la stratégie de vaccination qui sera
donc déployée en france pour plus de
précisions nous sommes en direct avec
notre reporter bassem chez vive
boussouar bassène que peut-on retenir du
plan du gouvernement sur les
vaccinations
bonsoir stéphanie écouter jean castex
vient de quitter il y à quelques minutes
l'assemblée nationale après environ
trois heures de débats des débats qui
ont succédé à cette allocution de jean
castex devant les députés à l'assemblée
nationale et puis d'olivier veyrat le
ministre de la santé ils sont venus pour
présenter les fondements et les
modalités de cette campagne de
vaccination prévue par le gouvernement
le premier ministre a parlé d'un motif
d'espoir qualifiant cette campagne de
vaccination il a voulu jouer la carte de
la transparence c'est ce qu'il a annoncé
au début même de son discours une carte
la transparence qui voulait jouer auprès
des français surtout auprès des députés
pourrait vite ils tous les cafouillages
qu'on a pu rencontrer notamment autour
de cette polémique autour des vaccins
qu'on a pu connaître pendant la première
vague du coronavirus le premier ministre
est revenu sur les modalités
d'acquisition de ce vaccin il a parlé
d'une sécurisation der approvisionnement
en vaccins du prix qui sera identique à
celui des voisins européens est
également au niveau de la livraison qui
sera simultanée avec tous les pays de
l'union européenne 200 millions de doses
sont prévues en livraison pour la france
pour 100 millions de patients car il
faut savoir ces deux doses par patient
deux laboratoires ont été choisis par
l'ensemble des partenaires européens à
savoir le laboratoire moderna et leur
bord at war files heures la mission qui
va être celle du gouvernement dans un
premier temps bien sûr c'est
l'identification des personnes
prioritaires et ce sera la mission de la
haute autorité de santé qui prévoit
notamment de commencer par les personnes
âgées les personnes en ehpad
le premier ministre a annoncé qu' il y
aurait sûrement une première vague de
vaccination à partir de la fin du mois
je vous propose est d'écouter à ce sujet
jean castex le premier ministre notre
campagne débutera conformément à cet
avis par les personnes les plus âgées
accueillies dans les établissements
comme les ehpad
cette première phase concerne environ un
million de personnes
et cette campagne mesdames et messieurs
les députés va débuter dans les tout
prochains jours dès que nous aurons eu
la décision d'autorisation de mise sur
le marché de l' agence européenne du
médicament qui est attendu qui est
attendu le 21 décembre prochain
dans la foulée la haute autorité de
santé donnera son avis concernant les
conditions d'utilisation du vaccin
c'est à partir de là que nous pourront
officiellement lancer notre campagne
vaccinale
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
les premières vaccinations pourraient
donc être réalisés dès la dernière
semaine du mois de décembre avant de
monter en puissance à partir de début
janvier
alors vous l'aurez compris un objectif
d'une première vague de vaccination à
partir de la fin du mois de décembre
elle durer normalement entre 6 à 8
semaines et puis dans la foulée il y
aurait une deuxième vague de vaccination
qui se concernerait cette fois ci plus
de 14 millions de français surtout les
personnes à risque des personnes qui
vivent à leur domicile jean castex à
evreux et veillez aussi à préciser qu
aucune vaccination serait fait sans eau
concernant consentement des différents
patients
cette première vague de vaccination à
l'ensemble des vagues de vaccination
elles sont accompagnées par une instance
nation indépendante qui sera créée par
le gouvernement un conseil d'orientation
de la stratégie vaccinale composé de
scientifiques de spécialistes et de
médecins
leurs objectifs et leurs buts surtout
c'est d'accompagner le ministère de la
santé dans cette campagne de vaccination
le communiste est revenu également sur
l'obligation et l'importance du
dépistage il a déclaré qu on était à 3
millions de dépistage par semaine des 3
millions de tests par semaine ce qui
n'était pas suffisant donc il va falloir
intensifier cette vaccination
voilà ce qu'on pouvait retenir
globalement de cette intervention du
gouvernement aujourd'hui
enfin des députés concernant cette
campagne de vaccination et bien sûr jean
castex et ils verront le miz la santé
réitérons le même exercice ça sera
demain devant les sénateurs
merci ben hassen chébili en direct de
l'assemblée nationale et à la sortie de
l'hémicycle les députés ont donc réagi
aux annonces ils sont loin d'être tous
convaincus écouté puisque nous attendons
du gouvernement dans ce débat qui va
commencer dans quelques instants c'est
d'avoir la stratégie en toute
transparence de a à z pas simplement de
grandes lignes de ce que le gouvernement
a l'intention de faire mais
véritablement quelle est sa stratégie
c'est qui va être vaccinés à quel moment
nous avons entendu jusqu'à présent des
bribes
c'est à dire un public prioritaire ce
que nous partageons
mais on a besoin de savoir quand
l'ensemble des français qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner pourront le faire au
aller aussi vite que possible mais pas
plus vite que la musique vous le disais
ce sont les membres de cette task force
interministériel les membres du
gouvernement qui sont les mieux informés
vous avez entendu les et veyran tout à
l'heure il a bien dit toutes les étapes
seront là si tous les feux sont au vert
je sais plus quelle expression clients
plus exactement
alors on se lance à mais c'est important
de le faire avec grande rigueur le défi
logistique est considérable pour
l'instant tout a été fait avec rigueur
et les 27 états membres de l'union
européenne pourront donc commencer le
même jouant leur campagne de vaccination
c'est ce qu'a annoncé ce matin la
présidente de la commission européenne
lieu suspendu à la validation du rhum
est développé par l'alliance peiser bio
un texte sous la pression de l'allemagne
notamment l'agencé européenne du
médicament se penchera sur la question
dès lundi soit une semaine plus tôt que
prévu je vous propose d'écouter en se
lavant der leyen
dans une semaine les premiers vaccins
seront autorisées pour que la
vaccination puisse commencer
immédiatement les autres suivront
l'année prochaine nous avons acheté plus
de doses que cela est nécessaire pour
tous les européens c'est une tâche
gigantesque donc commençons le plus
rapidement possible de cette vaccination
ensemble à 27
le même jour tout comme on fait preuve
d'unité au cours de sept cents et demi
comment sont ensemble à éradiquer cette
horrible virus et faisant le dans
l'unité et en ce qui concerne la france
on apprend tout juste à l'instant par la
bouche du premier ministre que 1,16
million de doses de vaccins seront
livrés à la france avant la fin de
l'année on laroque compris donc l'europe
qui accélère le pas sous la pression
peut-être de l'allemagne la france elle
se met au diapason et avancent elles
aussi les premières dates de vaccination
place à notre décryptage avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec un jean philippe dugoin clément
mais rudy de mennecy vice-président de
la région ile-de-france bonsoir rémy
rebeyrotte député la république en marge
de la 3ème circonscription de
saône-et-loire bonsoir à vous aussi
enfin alexis poulain éditorialistes
merci à tous les trois d'être avec nous
pour ce décryptage premières
vaccinations possible donc semaine dans
la dernière semaine de décembre si tout
va bien dit jean castex le premier
ministre on le rappelle inquiétant le
feu vert de cette fameuse agence
européenne du médicament il n'empêche la
date a tout de même été avancé on verra
pourquoi un petit peu plus tard plutôt
une bonne nouvelle ou pas assez prudent
rémy rebeyrotte nouvelle avec un premier
ministre
une grande humilité je suis pas griller
les étapes
les choses progressivement d'abord
l'autorisation européenne sous sous
j'allais dire là la pression de
l'ensemble des pays
bien sûr les temps sont des pays bien
sûr que dès que nous sommes en mesure de
pouvoir commencer la vaccination il faut
pouvoir le faire mais dans des
conditions de sécurité et une
connaissance parfaite au 16 c'est ce
qu'a souligné historiquement la france
va reçoit près d'un million deux cent
mille vaccin d'ici la fin de l'année
pour pouvoir commencer cette campagne de
vaccination notamment à destination des
plus anciens en institutions et des
personnes
les plus fragiles et des personnels
soignants sont vraiment la volonté du
gouvernement et s'était soumis par les
autres collègues députés
la présentation a été à la fois
efficaces
p6 et en même temps extrêmement
organisés de telle sorte que nous
puissions avoir des saignements dit ce
soir il nous permet d'avancer
concrètement vous êtes un député la
république en marche plutôt heureux ce
soir est convaincue par le premier
ministre c'est vrai que l'exercice de
pédagogie on l'aura compris absolument
primordial dans cette campagne de
vaccination avec des français en grande
majorité très sceptique vous partager
cet optimisme
jean philippe dugoin clément le premier
mise vous at il convaincu cet après midi
je sais pas s'il faut parler d'optimisme
ou pas ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il faut
avancer sur ce sujet et avancer
rapidement au moins pour les personnes
les plus fragiles qui souhaitent pouvoir
se faire vacciner
les vaccinations ont commencé outre
atlantique outre-manche on va être
globalement sur les même timing en
démarrant lundi prochain je pense que
les autorités sanitaires s'agissant des
mêmes vaccins avons donné les mêmes avis
il n'y a pas de raison que ce qui est
validée en angleterre qui était encore
un pays membre de l'union européenne il
ya huit jours ne le soit pas par l'union
européenne
donc on va pouvoir avancer dessus je
crois qu'il ya une véritable nécessité
de sécuriser les personnes les plus à
risque on sait que le taux de risque ce
n'est absolument pas le même sur des cas
graves en fonction de la typologie de
personnes touchées par cette pandémie
et si on n'arrive pas à avancer sur ce
sujet là je pense qu'on ne sortira pas
de la situation économique et sociétal
qu'on traverse et qui va avoir des
conséquences absolument terrible donc il
faut qu'on avance vite là dessus bon ce
qui a été présenté à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai pas eu l'ensemble des
débats mais sur ce que j'ai pu en voir
c'était des positions très généraliste
maintenant va falloir rentrer dans le
détail voir comment est-ce que ça va
être déclinée de manière concrète et
puis le sujet qui m'interroge un petit
peu plus c'est la durée de vaccination
puisque visiblement on nous dit que sur
les publics non à risque qui
souhaiteraient
ou non prioritaires qui souhaiteraient
pouvoir se faire vacciner on parle de la
fin du printemps c'est à dire quelque
chose à six mois ce qui semble
extrêmement long par rapport à
aujourd'hui après chacun est libre on
est sur une vaccination non obligatoire
mais on sait aussi qu'il y a chan un
socle barrière si on veut qu'une
vaccination puisse être efficace par
rapport à un virus
donc moi ce qui m'interroge un petit peu
c'est la question de la méthode déjà et
puis de la durée effectivement cette
question de durée à il faudra attendre
le printemps pour la majorité des
français alexis poulain il n'empêche
qu'on attend dans ce sera un million de
personnes visées dans les ehpad dans un
premier temps sauf que quand on
interroge les directeurs d'ehpad et bien
et nous disent en substance qu'ils ne
sont pas prêts pour l'instant que ça va
être un vrai casse tête à mettre en
place
est-ce qu'on se précipite pour la photo
si j'ose dire
c'est un petit peu la course à
l'échalote on voit les premiers avec ça
en russie aux etats-unis en
grande-bretagne et il ne faut pas que la
france soit à la traîne cette fois ci
alors qu'on n'est pas finalement si près
que cela oui j'ai l'impression que ce
sera surtout une campagne de
communication pour la première vague de
vaccins avec les caméras avec l'arrivée
en fanfare du vaccin mais pour ce qui
est de la logistique comme le dit cédric
villani c'est un vrai casse tête c'est
compliqué avec bien sûr le vaccin est
reine qui doit être stocké à moins de 80
degrés avec aussi le dispositif de kehl
qui pourraient être les ehpad qui vont
être livrés pourront-ils être tout ce
qu'ils veulent on parle de dix mille
établissements
et puis cette vaccination en deux phases
à une injection et puis une deuxième à
21 jours donc pour l'organisation de
tout ça il faut se préparer mais on n'a
pas l'impression qu'on n'est plus
préparé que ça en france on a vu la
préparation pour les masquer ça a été un
fiasco terrible lord du premier
confinement lors de la première vague là
on risque d'avoir une mise en scène pour
les vaccins avant la fin de l'année pour
dire qu'on fait comme tout le monde
qu'on suit les voisins européens et
qu'on arrive en tête du peloton des pays
qui vaccinent mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que la campagne de
vaccination va commencer en cette fin
d'année je pense que c'est la campagne
de communication sur la campagne de
vaccination qui va commencer et c'est
important je crois pour les différents
partenaires européens de faire cette
campagne ensemble pour
voir avoir un effet levier et pousser
les gens à se faire vacciner en regarder
nos voisins italiens nos voisins
allemands le font sans problème alors
allez-y français vous ne risquez rien
alors justement c'est l'allemagne qui
semble-t-il a pressé le pas et qui
demande à l'ordre d'aller plus vite à
l'image des anglais écouter jens aux
pannes le ministre allemand de la santé
nous voulons un examen approfondi
une approbation ordonnée et en même
temps un examen rapide nos autorités
nationales comme d'autres soutiennent au
mieux les autorités européennes
notre objectif est une approbation avant
noël nous voulons toujours commencer à
vacciner cette année en allemagne avant
la fin de l'année c'est une bonne
nouvelle que l'approbation puisse être
accordée le 23 décembre dans l'état
actuel des choses c'est à dire si les
données qui sont actuellement traités
sont disponibles
nous pouvons être optimistes sur le fait
que l'approbation pourra être accordée
le 23 décembre ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'ensemble de l'union
européenne les ministres allemand à
l'instar de la chancelière qui demandait
qu'on accélère le pas du coup la date de
la réunion
la commission européenne a été avancée
au 21 décembre
on sait de rémy rebeyrotte d'une
certaine manière à la pression allemande
alors que beaucoup de français
souhaiteraient de la prudence et de la
lenteur même peut-être dans ce dossier
tant ils sont sceptiques
on sait n'a aucune pression particulière
venir les allemands mais comme nous dès
que nous serons en situation bâti notre
père moi je suis toujours fasciné
on communie on nous dise une campagne de
communication sur le communiqué alors là
on dit mais vous ne communiquez pas en
campagne de communication c'est que tout
simplement on va pouvoir commencer à
vacciner avec une organisation sur
lequel le gouvernement ne se pense pas
qu'à partir de ce soir imaginez bien que
depuis plusieurs mois le gouvernement
travaille avec nos homologues sur les
techniques logistiques les manières dont
11 en a visionné lui centré mettre en
place la campagne
vaccinations à jour à lire quand même
que cette crise c'est une formidable
j'allais dire démonstration de l'europe
un sens la manière dont nous avons pu
gérer au plan européen que ce soit
d'ailleurs les décisions économiques et
financières les questions d'organisation
globale et là sur la vaccination
la possibilité de pouvoir travailler
ensemble et donc d'avoir les meilleures
conditions de se procurer le vaccin
c'est autant de démonstrations
s'il en était encore besoin non
seulement de l'unité et de l'utilité de
l'union européenne et de sa capacité au
niveau du continent à organiser des
choses et quand je regarde ce qui s'est
passé sur d'autres continents et
notamment sur le continent américain
un jour papa nous ayons tout à faire
passer même si nous sommes tous
confrontés à une crise de sens alors
évidemment il ya encore pas mal de
questions à le premier ministre la met
lui même je propose de regarder cette
infographie sur les six vaccins pré
commandé par l'union européenne il y en
a 3 ans vous les voyez à gauche de votre
écran qui semble au point et dont on
connaît les données et leur efficacité
father moderna et astrazeneca trois
autres à droite 1 qui sont en phase iii
ou qui ont pris beaucoup de retard
sanofi curve ac
johnson & johnson alors si les données
de son backbone y aura moins de deux
vaccins disponibles nous en inquiéter
jean philippe dugoin clément c'est
encore un petit peu la confusion
oui je crois qu'il ya quand même un
petit peu de marge ce qui est commandé
ces 200 millions de doses sears et la
possibilité puisqu'il faut deux doses de
vaccin au moins pour les premiers parce
que les vaccins suivant pour être admis
en une dose mais c'est la possibilité de
vacciner 100 millions de personnes ya 67
68 millions de français on sait par
nature la vaccination étant pas
obligatoire qui est une quote part de la
population qui est anti vaccin et qui ne
se fera pas vacciner
on sait encore plus sur ce sujet que il
ya des polémiques ya des inquiétudes qui
font que le taux de refus de vaccination
peut être un peu plus élevé donc la
potentialité d'avoir des français qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner qu'il n'ait
pas accès aux vaccins
à mon avis est assez minime
le sujet qui va se poser c'est
véritablement l'accès rapide pour ceux
qui souhaitent pouvoir se faire vacciner
donc c'est effectivement défi logistique
c'est ce qui était évoqué tout à l'heure
notamment du fait des températures de
conservation et de transport des vaccins
qui sont beaucoup plus basses que ce qui
est fait d'habitude et donc qui pose des
problèmes techniques importants et sur
lequel je pense que l'état aura besoin
de s'appuyer sur le secteur hospitalier
mais aussi sur les collectivités
territoriales pour pouvoir aller décliné
dans les territoires et puis la deuxième
chose c'est pas une course il ya peu une
course à la recherche enfin il ya peu
une course européenne on voit que pour
le coup on est sur le même calendrier
que les autres grands pays l'union
européenne après une date unique pour
mettre en place ces vaccins sur
l'ensemble des pays et on n'est pas sûr
avec cinq français en l'espèce le vexin
français c'est celui qui a pris six mois
de retard on l'aura si tout va bien en
milieu fin d'année proche fin d'année
prochaine
donc c'est pas une course mais c'est
vraiment rassuré des gens parce qu'il ya
quand même une quote part d'inquiétudes
moi je pense qu'on pourrait avoir
intérêt à ce que des membres du
gouvernement se fasse vacciner pour
donner un symbole pour marquer le fait
que ceux qui gouvernent n'ont pas
d'inquiétude sont prêts à le faire je
pense que symboliquement c'est important
d'avoir cette logique d'exemplarité en
tout cas de la part de quelques
ministres et puis au delà de ça c'est
vraiment pouvoir répondre vite pour ceux
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
ça va être un challenge énorme
effectivement le challenge énorme et
celui aussi on l'a dit un vous parliez
du scepticisme des français alexis
poulain ce scepticisme on le rappelle ce
chiffre assez impressionnant 61% des
français qui ne compte pas se faire
vacciner est ce qu'il peut représenter
un futur échec dans cette campagne de
vaccination et par conséquent dans la
lutte contre le virus
je crois que les les français on est le
pays des cartes dont qu'ils attendent
des preuves ils attendent de savoir si
ce vaccin fonctionne parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des études médicales
certes on a des annonces des
laboratoires qu'à 3 4 % de taux de
réussite mais on ne sait toujours pas si
ce vaccin permet de stopper la contagion
par yeom ça a été dit par jean castex
qui entend beaucoup de choses qu'on ne
sait pas donc en fait les premières
vagues de vaccination ou permettent de
voir si ce vaccin est efficace
quel est son degré réel d'efficacité une
fois qu'il est dans les populations
et puis aussi quelle est sa durée de
couverture puisque cette technologie arn
c'est une technologie nouvelle
on se félicitant des avancées de la
science est formidable mais on est au
niveau du prototype puisqu'on a accéléré
toutes les mises sur le marché
que ce soit les autorités de santé que
ce soit les fonds qui ont été débloqués
de manière incroyable souvent ce qui
fait que les vaccins mais beaucoup de
temps à être développé c'est qu'il
manque de moyens et que les autorités de
santé mettent beaucoup de temps avant de
donner leur aval là on a tout fait pour
que tout aille très vite parce que le
virus est d'une ampleur inédite mais on
ne sait pas finalement si ça va être
aussi brillant que annoncé sur le papier
donc je crois que les français font
comme tout le monde ils attendent de
voir pour croire
il préfère attendre sans doute que les
preuves de ces vaccins soit faite
derrière il n'ya pas une volonté
obscurantistes anti-vaccins on est le
pays de pasteur dont là on l'a redit
suffisamment c'est un nouveau produit et
technologie arn n'est pas avec 5 comme
les autres donc c'est là que le doute
c'est là qu'est la question sur
l'efficacité
quant à la dangerosité je crois que là
elle est minimiser au maximum par les
laboratoires qui ne mettraient pas sur
le marché un produit dangereux par les
autorités de santé également qu'ils vont
faire un travail de deux de suivi des
premiers vaccinés pour être sûr qu'ils
aient pas comme on l'a vu dès plastique
faciale des des problèmes dus à aux
injections de ces vaccins mais le vrai
souci aujourd'hui je crois c'est
l'efficacité réelle des vaccins est ce
que ces vaccins sont là pour redonner la
confiance dans les marchés redonner
confiance dans les populations ils ont
ça y est on va enfin voir le bout du
tunnel de cette pandémie
ou est ce que c'est un médicament qui va
être vraiment efficace et très
rapidement efficace rémy rebeyrotte
comment regagner la confiance de ses
français parce qu'on a vu ce monsieur
avec ça alain fischer ya plus d'une
semaine nous dire voilà pour l'instant
moi j'ai pas vu les études
bon il a exprimé clairement son
scepticisme est en tout cas il a été
franc ce matin le même alain fischer
nous dit on pas écouté la sai et
l'efficacité semble
acquise on est optimiste c'est vrai que
ça interroge comment convaincre les
français éviter cette défiance envers ce
vaccin est parfois envers tout
simplement les autorités qu'ils ne
croient plus s'est en d'abord n'avons
pas le monopole des personnes y voir une
rapport à la vaccination même si c'est
très fort nombreux pays
c'est vrai peut dédier à à 10 heures
et c'est dedans où on a sauvé des
vacciner en masse
ça c'est pas vrai la chaîne a aussi et
puis tout ce qui circule aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui effectivement mais
pas que dans le cadre de la baptisation
d'ailleurs aurait tendance à des
légendes de la bonne foi voilà je vous
propose ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
choisi la laissait vraiment leur
l'ontarien se refaire parce que voilà et
je vais passer par l'expérience parce
que nous allons vivre une petit à petit
des personnes seront convaincus il
faudra et qu'il est intéressant de se
faire vacciner que c'est même un élément
majeur qui rejoignait eni faudra aussi
que ou sommet de l'état mais ailleurs
président de l'association des maires
visiblement un peu de mal à se
convaincre lui-même de la vaccination
puisse être incliné et que ça incite
aussi six collègues à faire le pas voilà
mon jeu je pense qu'à un moment donné le
le bon sens l'emportera
je pense qu'effectivement dans notre
pays vouloir contraindre
c'est quasiment gelé dire s'assurer dany
shek vaut mieux nous par la conviction
par les garanties que nous avons honoré
il a été rare effectivement en reparle
par le pex fils qui se penche à
l'assemblée nationale sur les garanties
scientifiques
lui considère qu' il n'y aura vraiment
appuyé sur la vaccination et que le
vaccin serait cas c'est l'avis des
scientifiques
moi je me réfère à l'avis des
scientifiques chaque année je me fais
vacciner 2
et c'est vrai que depuis je suis vacciné
de la glisse mais s'attaque d'abord je
suis portée cela par ailleurs eh bien je
constate que c'est moins fort et même
que c'est très positif pour ce qui me
concerne en matière d'écologie voilà
c'est comme ça les choses doivent se
faire par l'expérience et aussi par le
bon sens jean-philippe du coin clément
vous justement l'homme de terrain le
maire l'appel du pied de rémy rebeyrotte
vous y êtes sensible il faudra que les
maires en tout cas il ya un rôle sur le
terrain un rôle de pédagogie auprès des
administrés ça va être une tâche
difficile
oui on peut avoir un rôle
d'accompagnement aussi l'état souhaite
que nous l'ayons si on nous demande et
qu'on nous présente un cadre avoir
dessus je crois que savez on a décrié
depuis des années cette france des 36000
maintenant un peu moins 35 mille
communes c'est aussi un maillage
territorial assez exceptionnel bas
puillon nous dessus l'un des sujets ça
va être de descendre dans les
territoires ça va être d'expliquer ça va
être de relayer donc je pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer sur ces outils qu'on a qui
marche le milieu associatif et quelque
chose
le maillage hospitalier malheureusement
depuis des années a diminué
bon réforme après réforme il reste les
communes donc je pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer dessus
et moi je crois vraiment à l'incitation
je reviens sur ce qui a été dit on est
un pays qui se cabre quand on veut
imposer des choses on est dans le pays
de 89 et 93
on est dans un pays qui ne supportent
pas la contrainte et où il faut vraiment
il y aller petit à petit permettre à
ceux ils sont nombreux qui souhaitent
pouvoir se faire vacciner le plus vite
parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
parlent de ce qu'ils ont peur des effets
secondaires ou d'une inefficacité mais
il ya aussi des gens qui ont peur du
virus et qui attendent de pouvoir se
faire vacciner
donc je pense qu'il faut cela leur
permette de se faire vacciner très vite
et puis de proche en proche et bien si
les français tels saint thomas voit
qu'effectivement il ya des progrès en
france qui a des progrès à l'étranger
les choses prendront mais ça on ne
pourra le faire que par la force de la
conviction et par le retour d'expérience
il ya par exemple
merci jean philippe dugoin clément rémy
rebeyrotte et alexis poulain d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage après donc
une audition en fin d'audition
les réponses aux questions des députés
de jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
sur la campagne de vaccination rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du coc vide en europe cette
fois à quelques jours de noël et la
situation qui est préoccupant tout les
pénis euros confine comme notamment aux
pays bas ou en allemagne depuis
aujourd'hui les pays restent très
vigilants comme l'avait belgique puis
direction les états unis où la campagne
de vaccination elle bat son plein de
président élu joe biden annoncé qu'ils
ne seraient prêts à se faire vacciner en
public
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que c'est une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c'est lié n'oublions pas que
tous nos problèmes viennent du mépris
qu'on a sur le reste du monde vivant
donc il faut il faut arrêter de laisser
les chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je
suis poli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez l'europe foyer de
l'épidémie de covin face à la flambée de
nouveaux cas de contamination
l'allemagne entame ainsi aujourd'hui son
confinement pour la première fois en une
seule journée
le pays a enregistré plus de 950 décès
liés au virus et précision de notre
correspondant en berne a1 pitaro l'hiver
l'allemagne entamé en reconsidérant
national mercredi qui courra jusqu'au 10
janvier au moins cette période s'est
ouverte avec une sombre nouvelle un
nouveau record du nombre de décès liés
aux cours aux navires us en 24 heures
952 personnes ordre de lakovic 19
c'est un record qui suit de très près le
précédent à peine quelques jours de 598
décès cela représente une hausse
considérable du nombre des morts avec le
nouveau confinement
tous les commerces non essentiels sont
fermés c'est à dire tout ce n'est pas un
supermarché où une pharmacie coiffeur et
salons de beauté avait pu rester ouverts
mais sont maintenant eux aussi fermés
juste avant l'entrée en vigueur du
confinement
ces allemands étaient dans les rues pour
se dépêcher de faire leurs dernières
courses de noël en personne le nouveau
confinement a été décidé ce week-end
contre le gouvernement fédéral à berlin
et les dirigeants des 16 régions
d'allemagne
il s'y fait de confinement aller j'ai
mis en place des lunes vente et qui n'a
au concrètement pas fonctionné ce qu'ont
reconnu tous les responsables
dhr à berlin les maisons de retraite ont
été les plus touchées en contamination
commander c'est plus de la moitié des
décès dans la capitale allemande ont été
enregistrés dans les maisons de retraite
la chancelière allemande angela merkel a
demandé de rester autant que possible à
distance des membres plus âgés du cercle
familial car la possibilité de leur
transmettre la copie de 19 pour être
avoir d'autres lots de conséquences à
long terme il y aura un léger
radoucissement de ces nouvelles
restrictions entre le 24 et le 26
décembre
tel est le message fondamental est que
le virus ne prend pas de vacances et
qu'il faut limiter les contacts d'autres
termes la période de noël ne sera pas
très festif en allemagne avec la mise en
place du confinement le plus strict que
le pays ait connu depuis l'apparition du
virus
une situation sanitaire qui se dégrade
également aux pays bas les néerlandais
sont confinés depuis hier jusqu'au 19
janvier
une mesure stricte qui là encore à
quelques jours de noël ne passe pas
auprès des commerçants les détails avec
robin pu l cinq semaines sous cloche
les pays bas ont débuté ce mardi une
période de confinement afin de lutter
contre la propagation du coronavirus
avec un taux d'incidence près de deux
fois supérieur à celui de la france
le gouvernement néerlandais craint une
explosion des contaminations pendant les
fêtes
une mesure drastique qui a du mal à
passer pour les commerçants à quelques
semaines de noël un confinement n'est
pas vraiment la solution mais une
application plus stricte des règles
sanitaires comme le port obligatoire
d'un masque même dans les centres
commerciaux votre température devrait
être contrôlé ainsi vous saurez
immédiatement qui a une température plus
élevée
c'est une solution bien plus efficace
qu'un confinement tous les magasins non
essentiels à l'exception des
supermarchés des magasins d'alimentation
et des pharmacies sont fermées musées
cinémas et salles de spectacles sont
également privés de public
pour faire face à cette situation
certains chefs d'entreprise s'adapte
dont l'une des rues commerçantes de
l'aïe
un propriétaire de restaurant a
transformé son établissement centre de
test à un moment donné nous avons parlé
avec un certain nombre de professionnels
de la santé et nous avons décidé de
créer un centre de test
c'est notre façon de contribuer à lutter
contre ce problème persistant nous
essayons à travers des tests de créer
des solutions pour avoir plus de liberté
pour nous mêmes et pour la vie
professionnelle
ces restrictions sanitaires sont les
plus sévères aux pays-bas depuis le
début de la pandémie en mars les
autorités néerlandaises avaient mis en
oeuvre en confinement allégé avec écoles
fermées mais les magasins eux étaient
restés ouverts et en belgique à présent
les restrictions liées aux commandes
sont assouplies pour les soirs de noël
et du jour de l'an sauf à bruxelles et
dans ses environs avec parce que 18000
décès depuis le début de l'épidémie la
belgique est l'un des pays qui a connu
le plus de morts proportionnellement à
sa population le couvre-feu actuelle se
poursuivra au moins jusqu'au 15 janvier
exceptionnellement il sera possible
d'être dehors jusqu'à minuit les soirs
de noël et du jour de l'an sauf donc à
bruxelles
dans la capitale il faudra être rentré à
22h après concertation avec le
gouvernement bruxellois et les 19
bourgmestres et au vu de la situation
épidémiologique
j'ai décidé de maintenir le couvre feu
durant les réveillons de noël et du
nouvel an il est en vigueur de 22 heures
à 6 heures jusqu'au 15 janvier 2021
cette période est difficile mais il faut
tenir le coup et pour en parler nous
sommes avec gilbert bun rany médecin
anesthésiste président de l'association
belge des syndicats médicaux bonsoir
jeannie merci d'être avec nous on le
voit des restrictions tout de même
imposé aux belges pendant les fêtes
c'était nécessaire selon vous oui
c'était nécessaire à cause
essentiellement du de la fatigue du
personnel soignant et de la pression que
le gouvernement ne veut plus mettre sur
les hôpitaux et donc c'était là la seule
chose à faire pour ne pas vivre une
troisième vague ou alors une deuxième
vague un peu prolongée parce qu'on voit
en belgique actuellement qu'on est en
train de de sortir de cette deuxième
vague
voilà le nombre de patients hospitalisés
en soin intensif est pourtant passé sous
la barre des 6 enfin c'est déjà trop
mais en tout cas voilà ça a tendance à
baisser pour la première fois en près de
deux mois on observe en revanche une
hausse des décontaminations c'est
justement vous venez de dire à
destination des hôpitaux cette mesure il
faut à tout prix baisser ces
hospitalisations et vider les hôpitaux
qui craquent en belgique
donc bien sûr que c'est des mesures de
prudence je pense et donc on peut
accepter ces mesures là je soutiens ces
mesures de prudence mais j'ai toujours
dit je pense qu'il faut apprendre aussi
à vivre avec le corps n'a donc le métier
des hôpitaux c'est de soigner et donc
avoir 2010 occuper enfin on a nous avons
2000 lits de soins intensifs
donc c'est quand même leur fonction de
d'être occupés par des patients qui sont
malades
ce qu'il faut c'est que qu'on ne dépasse
pas 7 bar c'est vrai qu'au sommet de la
delà de la deuxième vague
nous avions sept mille lits hospitaliers
occupés dont un peu plus que 1000 aux
soins intensifs mais il faut savoir
qu'il y a trente cinq mille lits
hospitaliers aiguë en belgique donc vous
voyez quand même bien que on a une
petite saturation du nombre de lits on a
déjà bloqué le pays
donc là la prudence s'imposait donc le
facteur limitant n'est pas le nombre de
lits mais c'est la disponibilité de
personnel soignant compétents et qui
peut assurer ses soins là et donc ça
c'est vraiment des personnes qui sont un
peu plus rare que les autres et c'est
pour ça que il fallait un peu les
préserver d'autant plus qu'on ne savait
pas vraiment que la deuxième vague
allait arriver si vite et donc c'est une
mesure de prudence qui est qui qui est
acceptable
au vu de la situation actuelle et qu'il
faut continuer pour pour vraiment
espérer ne pas avoir de troisième vague
avant l'arrivée du vaste d'autant
évidemment que la belgique est en
quelque sorte traumatisés comme leçon de
nombreux pays mais il n'empêche c'est
l'un des pays qui a connu le plus de
morts proportionnellement à sa
population
aujourd'hui avec quelques mois de recul
est ce que on s'explique
les raisons de ce mauvais bilan si j'ose
dire bah je pense que je les ai déjà dit
ce n'est pas un mauvais bilan il faudra
tirer le vrai bilan dans un an ou deux
la plaie la mortalité la plus importante
à pas avec ceux coronavirus et celle des
personnes très âgées de 80 ans 90 ans
et donc c'est vrai que on peut décéder
d'une fracture ou d'une chute ou d'un
autre problème de santé et être porteur
du virus à ce moment là donc ce qu'il
faudra faire s'est comparé la mortalité
globale dans le pays
d'une année à l'autre avec la mentalité
qu'on a qu'on a pu observer pendant
cette année de covit pour pouvoir dire
qu'un pays a fait mieux qu'un autre mais
donc aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un critère
très précis qui est celui du nombre de
morts qu'on peut attribuer aux vins au
courant d'un virus alors une lueur
d'espoir
ce vaccin dont tout le monde parle
notamment aujourd'hui l instant
d'ailleurs l'allemagne prévoit de
commencer sa campagne de vaccination le
27 décembre c'est ce qu'annonce le
ministre de la santé
cela valait
y'en avait l'air de dire que tous les
pays européens seraient logés à la même
enseigne donc ça pourrait être la même
chose pour vous les belges le 27
décembre pourquoi pas c'est quelque
chose que vous accueillez avec optimisme
prudent ce la vaccination l'accueil avec
ou de joie il y à un commissaire qui a
été nommée par le gouvernement pour
s'occuper du plan de d'organisation de
la vaccination
nous avons reçu déjà quelques
informations pour la vaccination en
trois étapes la première étape étant
bien sûr le personnel
enfin le personnel soignant mais aussi
donc l'ailé les patients les plus
fragiles
et puis donc les étapes suivantes pour
les le personnel à l'extérieur des
hôpitaux et et dans d'autres catégories
de patients et enfin le restant de la
population
le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire mais il
est conseillé et je pense que dans le
milieu des soignants en tout cas dans le
milieu où je vis beaucoup de personnes
vont se faire vacciner pour être
rassurés sur l'avenir
alors j'aimerais juste rappeler un point
fondamental qui est que le fait que le
corps la virus
à part la mortalité qui est quand même
importante dans certaines catégories
d'âge et bien et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas le seul problème donc je pense que
les jambes à se faire vacciner pour les
autres soucis de morbidité qu'il cause
notamment à part les problèmes
pulmonaires mais aussi des problèmes ne
fut-ce que de perte de goût et de
l'odorat
certaines personnes ont ça depuis le
mois de mars est donc on est quand même
à plusieurs moyennes n'ont toujours pas
récupéré
je pense que le vaccin il est utile pas
seulement pour éviter le décès mais pour
éviter les conséquences qui sont parfois
très lourdes au niveau de la vie
quotidienne et qui sont causés par ce
virus des séquelles importantes et
encore un navire russe merci à gilbert
bun rany d'avoir été avec nous en direct
donc de belgique merci à vous la russie
de son côté elle aussi poursuit à sa
campagne de vaccination de masse dix
jours après moscou les premières doses
sont arrivés dans plusieurs régions et
comme dans la capitale les premiers en
bénéficier sont le personnel de santé un
vaccin efficace à plus de 90% selon les
autorités françois tisci et beach dans
cet hôpital de vladivostok
cette infirmière s'apprête à injecter le
vaccin un vaccin totalement gratuit non
obligatoire fonctionnant en deux temps
avec une première injection suivie d'une
autre 21 jours plus tard je travaille
avec le co vie depuis mai j'ai vu
quelles pouvaient être les conséquences
j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux recevoir
une dose pour que mon corps soit prêt et
même si je la trappe
je m'en sortirai plus facilement j'ai
déjà vu des médecins se faire vacciner
par le passé et tout allait bien cela
m'a donné confiance
personne ne m'a forcée c'est absolument
volontaire des vaccins d'abord mis à la
disposition des populations les plus
exposées à la maladie médecins
travailleurs médicaux enseignants ou
encore travailleurs sociaux une campagne
de vaccination massive débuté le 5
décembre dernier à moscou et dont le
succès est primordial pour les autorités
elles qui ont renoncé un deuxième
confinement pour sauver l'économie du
pays une économie marquée par des mois
d'inflation entre janvier et novembre le
prix du sucre a augmenté de 70% les
pattes de 10% et l'huile de tournesol de
24%
autre indicateur inquiétant le chômage a
bondi à 6 3% en octobre contre 4 7% en
mars juste avant le confinement
printanier mercredi dernier
vladimir poutine a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
j'espère que la situation se stabilisera
à la semaine prochaine en l'occurrence
cette formulation ne me convient pas du
tout n'est pas de j'espère vous devez me
dire à partir de la semaine prochaine
nous allons stabiliser la situation chez
vous autant que le ministre russe du
développement économique
le président russe a chargé ses
différents ministres de mettre en place
des mesures d'urgence alors qu'il est
attendu ce jeudi pour sa traditionnelle
conférence de presse annuelle
et outre atlantique à présent le
président-élu prêts à se faire vacciner
en public joe biden soixante dix huit
ans présenté comme une personne à risque
attend les derniers conseils de
l'immunologiste anthony fauci
déclaration faite alors que la campagne
de vaccination a débuté en début de
semaine les autorités prévoient de
vacciner quelques 20 millions
d'américains avant fin décembre et 100
millions avant fin mars
le docteur foti me recommande de me
faire vacciner le plus tôt possible
je veux m'assurer que ce soit fait selon
la procédure et quand je le ferai vous
serez prévenus et je le ferai en public
et en plus du vexin pfizer bio ntech
celui de modern a devrait bientôt être
inoculé lagence états unienne des
médicaments ouvre la voie à une
autorisation en urgence je cite le vexin
de moderna ne présente pas de problème
de sécurité spécifiques identifiés avec
une efficacité évalué à 94,1 % est la
semaine dernière le ministère américain
de la santé a informé que 100 millions
de doses de ce dernier vexant avait été
commandée en complément des 100 millions
déjà acheté au laboratoire pfizer bio n
tech et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis new york avec est calé bas
mot pas un correspondant verte et aux
etats unis c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir khaled maupin merci d'être avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir joe
biden qui est donc prêt à se faire
vacciner en public cela rappelle
évidemment la démarche de barack obama
bill clinton et george bush c'est
important aux yeux des américains est ce
qu'ils partagent le même scepticisme que
les français face au vaccin ils ont
besoin d'être convaincu effectivement
qu'il va tout changer constamment la
pandémie est encore navires us il dit
que ses premiers 100 jours seront très
simples que le plus grand problème c'est
le manque approche imagi n'était pas
menacé a le soutien de porter des
masques aux différents hôtels
différentes approches
les petits commerces voulait sortir au
conflit mais aussi rapidement que
possible alors que les gros comme
raisonnement que d'autres voulaient
maintenir le confinement est celle
d'assurer des activités une émission je
ne savais pas trop quoi faire je byden
jours mais qu'il va être juste dans la
gestion précis à contrôler la pandémie
beaucoup espèrent qu'il réussira mais
d'autres pensent qu'on ne sera peut-être
pas à même de réussir alors les chiffres
ne sont pas bons en tout cas aux états
unis joe biden a évidemment du pain sur
la planche on a appris que le premier
test on qui gène ikke à domicile et sans
ordonnance pour 30 dollars arrivé sur le
marché était autorisée est ce que ça
peut changer beaucoup de choses on
compte beaucoup là dessus dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie
pour beaucoup c'est un retour à l'élite
ministration donne un côté considérés
comme des anomalies chaudes des noms
lishan six candidats pressentis ceinture
alors justement oui côté politique pitt
beauty jihadjane a été choisi par joe
biden pour intégrer son gouvernement au
ministre ministre des transports les
américains qui se souviennent bien de ce
candidat aux primaires démocrates c'est
une révélation justement de ces
primaires les américains se sont plutôt
favorables à ce choix s'est intéressé en
cas d'échec chez était le maire ce petit
à petit il s'est retrouvé à certains
propulsé sur la scène nationale et très
public avec son orientation sexuelle et
au gaz et les les agences du
renseignement américain a alerté la
gauche afin qu'elles se détournent de
marxistes et surtout les îles est une
très bonne carrière avec des connexions
avec les renseignements américains
annonce sa carrière mater en afghanistan
par exemple travaillé avec le
renseignement
il dit qu'il a travaillé avec la rue
mais en fait il a travaillé avec
certaines parties des élites américaines
les éléments stratégiques dans l'élite
était contre donald trump comme contre
100 opérations radical il préférer
d'autres façons de gérer les relations
internationales à long terme voulait
assurer la stabilité semble être plus
proche de ses factions là est ce ce
monsieur boutiquier également les
détracteurs des gens de joe biden
critique ses choix d'une manière
générale et nous disent eh bien voilà
c'est un petit peu en quelque sorte le
retour de l'élite de washington dans ce
gouvernement
considéré fait que personne n'ait
remporté six étapes à sept retraits sur
fraîcheur car il savait que quio dur que
de grands instituts seul tout fait tout
leur possible pour qu'ils gagnent
instructeur essaie d'étouffer les
informations concernant son fils lenteur
bikes et d'étouffer des psychotiques ci
contre
l'activité a également été étoffé les
nouvelles ont été gardés secrets par le
ministère de la justice car ils sont
sûrs et qui nous vous laissons en
chercher d'autres
cette ville et le media works qui
semblent croire au toc fait tout leur
horizon est construite et nos craintes
et d'établissements 7e match eupen
on a gagné mais on y gagne un tel
consensus avec autant de pression qu'on
donne à cannes devait partir mais
question que va-t-il se passer
que se passera-t-il si le savez se
maintenir pas aussi horrifiés
on pourrait dire que c'est une victoire
pour les démocrates avaient assez
d'événements et victoire pour les états
unis watchers remporté de justesse une
élection a été très compliqué et il ya
encore d'américains qui ont préféré
qu'on attrape tout malgré le fait que
l'établissement chinois de l'humain que
les médias étaient contre donald trump
et les inciter autrement merci khaled
maupin correspondant de rtl états unis
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du plan de vaccination
détaillé
jean castex à l'assemblée le premier
ministre qui annonce que les premières
vaccinations pourraient intervenir fin
décembre alors qu'on apprend à l'instant
que l'allemagne elle fera ses premières
vaccinations le 27 décembre et nous
reviendrons
surtout sur le procès des attentats de
2015 la cour d'assises spéciale de paris
a rendu son verdict avec des peines
allant de quatre ans à la perpétuité
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que notre
peuple accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du public
il est clair pour tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inné gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la dent chiper brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population et à étouars des porteurs de
causalité d'explications mais d'identité
un train si l'on veut dire de
l'appartement il ya les chaînes de
contagion des autos à l'intérieur
rassemblement milieu familial parce
qu'on a des familles qui vivent à trois
générations et c'est tout cet ensemble
de causes qui constitutionnellement un
syndrome en quelque sorte social et dont
le gaulliste est à la fois le révélateur
est malheureusement la cause
déterminante pompiers je suis très
frappé entre représentants des sciences
sociales par finalement le progrès
considérables qu'on a fait dans cette
pandémie qu'avant dérivation n'a pas que
des mauvais côtés en un an on a mis au
poids pratiquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise et non
vraie bêtise c'est à dire que vous
dépendrez entièrement de l'état le
problème du revenu ir sel c'est
effectivement il y aura une contrepartie
ce sera conva supprimer un certain
nombre d' aide c'est extrêmement
dangereux parce que finalement les 9 2
millions de pauvres
on a dans ce pays vont être encore plus
haut c'est un espèce de nivellement par
le bas c'est à dire tout le monde à 750
euros mais avec 750 euros vous pouvez
vivre les entreprises on attendait juste
plus la peine de payer 2000 euros les
gens ils ont déjà droit 700 euros on va
vite - là on parle de 400 milliards pour
faire un revenu universel et 400
milliards c'est 20 % ont pib on fait
comment on les sort d'où
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fond dans la politique c'est
la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et
plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique
trop de lois tuent la loi et les lois
inutiles culé vol nwa
[Musique]
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
16 décembre 2020 un vil 16 millions de
doses de vaccins seront livrés à la
france avant la fin de l'année annonce
de jean castex ce soir le premier
ministre qui a pris un peu plus tôt la
parole à l'assemblée nationale pour
détailler la stratégie du gouvernement
les premières vaccinations
interviendront dès la dernière semaine
de décembre mais pas avant la fin du
printemps pour la population non
prioritaires ce soir l'allemagne a
ajouté pierre vaccination le 27 décembre
trois mois après le lancement du procès
des attaques de janvier 2015 la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris a rendu son
verdict jugé les quatorze soutien
présumé des auteurs des attaques contre
charlie hebdo et l'hyper cacher la
qualification terroriste a été écartée
pour six des onze accusés présents et
sont en revanche reconnu coupable
d'association de malfaiteurs à yatta
boumédiène et ali riza polars sont eux
condamnés à 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle
ce dernier fait appel ouvrant la voie à
un nouveau procès le rafale fond son
envol le parlement grec a approuvé hier
le budget 2021 du pays qui prévoit
l'achat de 18 avions de combat à la
france coût total de 2,5 milliards
d'euros est la ministre française des
armées
florence parly est attendue la semaine
prochaine à athènes pour signer le
contrat
un achat dans un contexte de tension
accrue avec la turquie sur
l'exploitation d'hydrocarbures en
méditerranée orientale
il ya presque dix ans jour pour jour un
jeune vendeur ambulant s'est immolé dans
le centre de tunisie pour dénoncer ses
conditions de vie un événement tragique
a qui marquait le début d'une vague de
protestations populaires dans le monde
arabe egypte yémen libye bahreïn syrie
les soulèvements s'étendent comme une
traînée de poudre
alors que reste-t-il du printemps arabe
aujourd'hui nous nous en parlerons avec
nos amis
[Musique]
1,16 million de doses de vaccin seront
donc livrés à la france avant la fin de
l'année annonce de jean castex le
premier ministre qui un peu plus tôt ce
mercredi à l'assemblée nationale a pris
la parole pour détailler la stratégie de
vaccination prévue par le gouvernement
on fait le point avec les îles à saraf
avant le sénat ce jeudi l'épreuve de
l'assemblée nationale jean castex a
présenté sa stratégie de vaccination
les français ne devrait plus attendre
très longtemps cette campagne
mesdames et messieurs les députés va
débuter dans les tout prochains jours
dès que nous aurons eu la décision
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
l' agence européenne du médicament qui
est attendu qui est attendu le 21
décembre prochain
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
les premières vaccinations pourraient
donc être réalisés dès la dernière
semaine du mois de décembre
jean castex souhait de conserver les
grandes lignes du calendrier prévu avec
olivier ferrand
la semaine dernière le ministre de la
santé avait esquissé les trois phases de
la future campagne de vaccination
d'abord dans les ehpad début janvier
puis entre février et mars pour les
personnes présentant des facteurs de
risque ou les professionnels de santé
puis la campagne grand public à partir
du printemps
jean castex a également confirmé que la
france avait commandé 200 millions de
doses soit suffisamment pour vacciner
100 millions de personnes une stratégie
qui sera coordonné avec celles des
autres pays européens
un dispositif sur lequel le gouvernement
plancherait depuis plusieurs mois chacun
devra pouvoir se faire vacciner par un
professionnel de chanter à côté de chez
lui qu'il connaît et en qui il a
confiance
le dispositif sera étroitement concertés
avec toutes les parties prenantes
sous la responsabilité du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé ce n'est que
dans un troisième temps à la fin du
printemps que nous ouvrirons la
vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population comme les politiques de
l'opposition les français
restent sceptiques selon un sondage de
l'agencé sanitaire santé publique france
seule la moitié interrogé en novembre
veut se faire vacciner contre deux tiers
en juillet et pour en parler nous sommes
avec françois crasneanscki médecins
spécialistes de santé publique bonsoir
françois crémant ski merci à d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france avant
finalement la france qui avance
sadate en quelque sorte sous la pression
de l'allemagne peut-être c'est une bonne
chose il faut s'en réjouir ou au
contraire il fallait peut-être prendre
davantage le temps comme le disait
certains députés dans l'hémicycle que
cet après midi non moi je pense qu'il
faut au contraire s'en s'en réjouir plus
tôt on pourra commencer les campagnes
vaccinales plus tôt on pourra espérer
voir une sortie de de cette épidémie et
surtout plus tôt on pourra protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables
donc autant commencer dès que possible
d'autant que ce sera après tout de même
un certain nombre de vérifications
on a parlé de l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché par par l'ime inquiets
l'agencé du médicament européenne et qui
quand même va être en charge de
contrôler les études qui ont été
réalisées sur les vaccins donc des cures
alors à corps on peut quand même se dire
qu'il ya un minimum de risques pourront
pas dire aucun risque a lancé cette
campagne vaccinale dans le même temps
c'est vrai que quand on interroge les
directeurs des états non nous dit voilà
on n'est pas complètement prêt on sait
que les pensionnaires des ehpad vont
être les premiers vaccinés parmi les
prioritaires avec les soignants cette
première vaccination ça sera un petit
peu pour la photo pour la communication
il fallait dans les temps ou finalement
ça n'a pas tant d'importance que ça
l'essentiel c'est de commencer
l'essentiel c'est de commencer sans
discussion possible
aujourd'hui on voit les difficultés fin
là on a passé un pic épidémique
on est toujours sur une phase de plateau
qui est plutôt bas mais qui reste
présent on craint une
les uns comme l'allemagne l'a connu on a
des confinement qui est un peu entre
deux c'est à dire que voilà on a un peu
plus de souplesse mais on comprend qu'il
fallait maintenir un certain nombre de
mesures pour éviter une nouvelle flambée
donc là où on va passer des fêtes ma la
chance de pouvoir quand même oser faire
souffler un peu au moment de noël
d'avoir une possibilité de voir des
mesures et en respectant les gestes
barrière certes un certain nombre de nos
familles on remet un petit peu une
barrière au moment du nouvel an ce qui
est ce qui est bien c'est qu'on va
pouvoir le plus vite possible
protéger les plus vulnérables avec avec
ces vaccins et ce qui nous permettra par
la suite de sortir de cette qu'il vous
en tant que médecin vous allez
clairement le conseiller à partir de
quoi vous allez quand même exigé avant
de lire les milliers de pages d'études
scientifiques qui ont été écrites
justement sur sur les études des
différentes étapes de ces morts
réalisation de vaccins en tant que
médecin de santé publique
j'ai la chance de connaître un peu le
fonctionnement de ces études et des
différentes agences qui sont en charge
aussi de les contrôler est ce que je
peux vous dire aussi c'est que c'est
quand même des études qui sont qui sont
poussés
l'analyse des des données des résultats
est pas est pas donné à tout à chacun il
faut un certain niveau de connaissances
et de l'expérience pour pouvoir les
analyser
je vais pas vous mentir je n'ai pas lu
la totalité des études concernant les
vaccins mais je sais que ce qu'ils le
feront qui en sont chargées dans les
différentes agences et aussi au
gouvernement
en tout cas dans les ministères eux sont
très capables et sont souvent d'ailleurs
en france on a un pays on ait la chance
c'est d'être très critique sur les
résultats d'une très vigilant et il ya
des tours de très grandes précautions
sur la mise en place des différents
médicaments et ce sera le cas donc moi
en tant que médecin de santé publique
même si j'ai pas lu la totalité du
contenu je fais confiance en tout cas
aux autorités et aux agences il dit ce
qu' il n'y a pas de danger et bien
j'irai en tout cas dès que je pourrai
puisque je suis pas dans les populations
fragiles va me j'irai moi-même me faire
vacciner sans aucune hésitation comme je
le fais pour toutes les autres maladies
vous allez devoir attendre comme nous
d'ailleurs le printemps est ce que ce
n'est pas trop tard pardon françois
delfraissy 1 le président du conseil
scientifique nous rappelle justement
qu'il faut rester prudent que les effets
de ce vaccin il faudra les attendre
encore trois à six mois ce n'est pas un
petit peu trop long je pense qu'il faut
aussi il ya un principe de réalité on a
un certain nombre de doses qui vont qui
vont arriver au fur et à mesure je pense
que la stratégie elle est tout
simplement logique et pragmatiques les
plus vulnérables ceux qui risquent de
décéder et qui ont plus de facteurs de
risque en premier ceux qui sont ensuite
au contact de ces personnes plus
fragiles en 2d et puis ensuite on
descend dans le
dans le niveau de risque d'avoir des
formes graves donc moi c'est par être
tout à fait cohérent je vais pas faire
preuve d'égoïsme en me disant je vais
protéger le premier donc il faudrait
déjà un vaccin tout de suite
non moi je préfère que ce soit les
grands-parents les personnes âgées ou
les personnes qui ont des maladies
graves et qui risquent de mourir qu'ils
soient vaccinés en premier
après l'idéal évidemment ça a été de
pouvoir vacciner tout le monde le plus
vite possible maintenant il ya des
principes de réalité de production on
fait au mieux au plus tôt en vous lavant
les 10 en début d'interview
dès qu'on allait on commence à
vaccination pour protéger les plus
vulnérables
et puis ensuite on fait en fonction de
ce qu'on peut faire
ma dernière question en attendant il va
falloir respecter les mesures de
restriction l' oms qui aujourd'hui
recommande le port du masque lors des
réunions familiales
une réaction c'est la seule chose selon
vous pour éviter la troisième vague
alors non c'est pas la seule chose et ça
me permet d'insister sûr ce point le
masque c'est pas un terme cas médiatisés
mais c'est pas un totem d'immunité 1 ce
qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il ya toutes
les mesures barrières sont utiles pour
continuer à lutter contre la propagation
de cette épidémie
donc évidemment le masque en fait partie
le masque c'est pas encore une fois une
protection individuelle c'est une
protection collective c'est à dire c'est
utile si tout le monde joue le jeu et
j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus
tout le monde joue le jeu
mais il n'ya pas que cette mesure de
protection il ya aussi le lavage de
mains très régulier et aussi la
distanciation physique pour rappel c'est
minimum 1 m donc après en essayant de
faire au mieux chacun dans son quotidien
en fait on diminue le risque de
contamination et c'est ça le principal
puisque au fond c c'est cette notion de
risque qui est importante c'est pas tout
blanc ou tout noir tout ou rien plus on
applique les mesures plus on fait
attention et avec le vaccin et plus on
s'en sortirait collectivement et le plus
rapidement possible merci beaucoup
françois crasneanscki d'avoir été avec
nous médecins spécialistes de santé
publique merci à vous et les derniers
chiffres du coronavirus santé publique
france dénombre 17 1615 cas de co vite
détectés en 24 heures
donc par rapport à mercredi dernier 292
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital de
tout positivité s'établit à 6,2 pour
cent après trois mois d'audience le
verdict tombe au procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 à la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris s'est prononcée
concernant les peines la d14 soutien
présumé des auteurs des attaques contre
charlie hebdo et de l'hyper cacher les
attaques qui ont fait 17 morts les
précisions de notre reporter katia pique
nique à la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris
le verdict est tombé la qualification de
terrorisme n'a finalement pas été retenu
pour six des onze accusés c'est à dire
que la cour a établi une différence
entre les proches de mehdi koulibaly est
un réseau du nord accusée d'avoir fourni
ou transporter des armes
les juges ont estimé qu'il n'avait pas
eu conscience du projet terroriste alors
sans surprise ali riza paul est le
principal accusé a été condamné à 30 ans
de réclusion
d'autres accusés ont été condamnés à de
lourdes peines les jeux ont estimé
qu'ils avaient conscience du projet
criminel terroriste donc nezzar
pastorale wathiq 18 ans amar hamdani 20
ans willy prévost 13 ans d'autres
accusaient encore ont été condamnés pour
simple association de malfaiteurs ils
ont écopé de peines allant de 10 à
quatre ans de réclusion criminelle
un mot sur les absents mohamed
belhoucine a été condamné à la réclusion
à perpétuité et aya de boumédiène en
fuite
à 30 ans tandis que mehdi belhoucine a
déjà été jugé dans une autre affaire
finalement je vous propose d'écouter les
réactions des avocats des parties
civiles m elie korchia et maître richard
malka
je voudrais juste vous dire je ne peux
qu'avoir une pensée ce soir
à cette peine de 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle qui est exactement la même
qui a été celle prononcée pour le frère
de l'assassin terrorisme - nairas la
condamnation qui est aujourd'hui gravé
dans le marbre
et bien aujourd'hui ce soir ali riza
bolat autres complices de terroristes
assassins et condamné par la cour
d'assises à la même peine de 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle
il y avait un lien entre la matrice de
ses agents admis 2012 est l'année les
attentats de janvier 2015 c'est le même
antisémitisme qui a tué dans une école
juive que dans l'hyper cacher ça a été
parfaitement rappelé par le président de
la conasysed
dans sa motivation et cette peine de 30
ans de réclusion criminelle
c'est celle qui restera évidemment ce
soir lorsque nous entrons chacun et que
nous parlerons dans quelques instants
chacun pour participer donc dans son
père c'est la fin de quelque chose mais
j'espère aussi que c'est le début
d'autre chose
j'ai senti je crois en tout cas je
l'espère une prise de conscience un
éveil il n'a envie d'agir citoyenne les
avocats de la défense ont diversement
apprécié le verdict selon que les peines
soient lourdes plus légères je propose
d'écouter margot publié et qui défend
des miguel martinez ainsi que m vannerie
qui défend des halles et rue saint paul
est le principal accusé
la cour a officiellement reconnu que
monsieur martin n'était pas un
terroriste donc c'est un immense
soulagement parce que ça fait quatre ans
qu'il attend qu'on qu'on le croit qui
crie son innocence qui dit qu'il n'a
aucun lien avec les attentats et ça fait
quatre ans qu'il attend d'être entendus
et aujourd'hui c'est arrivé et c'est un
immense soulagement parce que pour lui
le plus important c'était qu'on lui dise
et qu'on dise à tout le monde qui
n'était pas terroriste monsieur miguel
martinez la cour d'assises aujourd'hui à
faire un copier coller de l' ordonnance
de mise en accusation en reprenant des
arguments qui pourtant tout au long de
l'audience avait été balayé par exemple
la recherche d'appartement paramédics
coulibaly on le sait aujourd'hui qu'elle
a été faite par hamidou coulibaly à son
nom avec son adresse mail
or dans sa motivation la cour d'assises
dit monsieur paul apte à rechercher
l'appartement conspiratif de monsieur
coulibaly donc pour toutes ces raisons
il est bon aujourd'hui d'interjetter
appel et que peut-être
les faits soient jugés avec un regard
plus extérieur mois médiatique après
presque trois mois et demi d'un procès
extrêmement poignant extrêmement
douloureux certaines victimes et avocats
de parties civiles se sont dits soulagés
certains avocats de la défense également
d'autres feront appel c'est le cas de la
défense d'ali risa paul at donc le
procès fleuve est historique mais
peut-être pas fini - des peines lourdes
mais pas maximale au terme d'un procès
historique donc le procès des attentes
at il rendu justice aux victimes quel
message envoie la société française quid
des condamnés qui sortiront prison après
quelques années pour certains derrière
les barreaux c'est l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
ziya oloumi avocat spécialiste défense
des libertés et droits des étrangers
bonsoir il ya oloumi merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés wilfrid donc secrétaire
national du syndicat ufap/unsa-justice
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là on le
disait des peines lourdes mais pas
maximale une réaction ziya onomie sur
l'ensemble en tout cas de ce verdict
rendu par la cour d'assises spéciale ce
soir c'est visiblement un verdict mitigé
puisque vous avez d'une part d'un
certain dégoût frères qu'ils sont
d'accord avec cette aide la position de
la cour et d'autres qui vont faire appel
vous avez du côté des victimes également
de la majorité qui sont d'accord avec la
position de la course
ce qui est important dans ce dans ce
cadre là c'est de distinguer entre ceux
qui ont été reconnus terroristes et les
autres je pense que et tout à l'heure
c'est 2 pour la france de bien montrer
que dans une justice qui est un peu
médiatisé ben on peut quand même garder
la tête froide et prononcé des peines
qu'ils soient justes pour l'instant doha
visiblement d'après ce qu'on a compris
un appel en tout cas prendre partie des
personnes condamnées
donc je me réserverai pour la suite mais
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui ça donne
cette impression au regard des trois
mois de procès que une page se tourne
mais c'est pas terminé
une justice qui n'était pas sous
pression en tout cas qui a rendu justice
à nous disiez à oloumi en substance
wilfried de fond que c'est votre avis
également un procès l'auteur né des
événements qui se sont déroulés
c'est au niveau de l'ufap unsa justice
on n'a pas pour habitude de commenter
les décisions de justice nous notre
métier c'est surtout d'exécuter des
décisions du 6 et aujourd'hui quand on
voit les quantum de peine qui peuvent
être prononcées notamment depuis 2015
on se rend compte que les quantum sent
de plus en plus élevés avec des
individus qui vont se retrouver
incarcéré pour des 20 30 ans 30 ans pour
certains avec des périodes de sûreté des
deux tiers généralement est donc
derrière la vraie question qui se pose
en tout cas pour nous personnels
pénitentiaires c'est quelle prise en
charge dans quel type de structure alors
justement ça c'est une vraie question a
dit yao nomi parce que on est dans le
cadre d'un procès exceptionnel avec
évidemment des faits d'une gravité
exceptionnelle beaucoup de ces accusés
pour certains en tout cas vont faire des
peines l'imité quelques elle suit pour
eux dans quelles conditions vont ils
être incarcéré de manière favorable en
tout cas en fait si vous voulez ce qui
est important aujourd'hui c'est que
alors on part d un des confrères parler
de la prise de conscience
aujourd'hui nous avons un vrai problème
pour le traitement des personnes qui
sont condamnées pour le terrorisme
donc je disais sans parler de ceux de ce
dossier plus particulièrement ce qu'il
faut connaître le dossier précisément au
pouvoir se prononcer mais en tout état
de cause ces personnes qui vont faire
effectivement 20 ans ne seront pas bien
sur leurs représentants de syndicats
pourra le dire également ne vont pas
être dans des quartiers qui sont ô prévu
à cet été pour les terroristes
pour ne pas être qu'à laisser d'autres
personnes et aux gens qui nous
connaissons de l'état de nos prisons
tous les ans des rapports qui sortent
récemment rien de nouveaux rapports qui
disent qu effectivement l'état des
prisons sont catastrophiques
donc aujourd'hui de façon les
prisonniers de droit commun se sont dans
un état particulièrement difficile
donc ces personnes qui arrivent
représente un vrai problème pour
notamment les le personnel pénitencier
parce que il faut savoir les gérer
je disais encore une fois il y aura sans
doute des appels donc dans ce cadre là
ces personnes ne seront pas considérées
comme condamné pour l'instant en
l'occurrence donc ils seront toujours
considéré comme il ne s'en jusqu'à ce
que la
arrêt définitive n'intervienne
éventuellement dans cette affaire mais
en tout état de cause c'est un vrai
souci un vrai problème qui se pose à la
fois aux droits parce que dans le droit
alors vous avez résumer ma pensée en
disant que c'était des peines juste je
le disais simplement qu' il fallait
quand même vérifier l'intention parce
que vous avez une partie des personnes
qui disaient qu'ils n'avaient pas
l'intention terroristes or cette
intention terreau russe est un élément
car elle qui caractérise d'infraction
donc c'est important que dans la veille
qu'on verra sans doute prochainement
tous ces éléments soient caractérisées
parce que sinon ça donne cette
impression qu'on a parfois quand on
défendre les dossiers deux entre
guillemets terroriste que le les juges
vont trop vite et ne qualifiez pas les
infractions dos ça c'est déjà un élément
parce que si ces personnes qui sont
condamnées sont condamnées entre
guillemets donc injustement sans
qualification de ces éléments notamment
l'élément intentionnel et bien vous
allez avoir des personnes qui pourront
toujours revendiqué cette injustice à
laquelle ils ont ils ont été victimes
d'injustices et ce six ce n'est jamais
bon même pour les personnes qui sont
condamnées
enfin justement diallo me pardonnez moi
mais la cour a écarté ans a surpris
beaucoup la qualification de terroriste
pour six des onze accusés présents ça
peut étonner
on a peut-être on entend déjà les
détracteurs parlent et peut-être de
laxisme dans la justice est ce que ça
peut être votre avis j'imagine que non
or en fait c'est très simple quand il
s'agit de justice médiatisé actuellement
ce qu'on a on s'attend à des peines
parce qu'on a déjà condamné ces
personnes puisqu'on considère là les
personnes la population considère
souvent que les personnes qui sont
amenés devant la justice sont déjà
condamnés or c'est pas car le la justice
son rôle c'est justement de permettre
aux uns et aux autres notamment la
défense de produire des éléments qui
vont justifier qu'ils vont démontrer que
le parquet ou le juge d'instruction n'a
pas effectivement caractériser les
éléments de constitutifs de l'infraction
et dans ce cadre là là où je disais
effectivement que les peines ne pouvait
être considérée comme juste peut-être
c'est que les personnes qui ont été
condamnées pour autre chose que le
terrorisme ont accepté lapins et de
l'autre côté les victimes visiblement
ont aussi accepté cette peine là on
verra ce que le parquet fera dans tout
état de cause dans une justice pénale
notamment il faut jamais oublier que ce
qui compte aussi c'est de permettre aux
deux à la fois aux victimes et à la
défense de confort se prononcer et de
d'être content de la sanction qui est
tombé donc il ya l'action pardonnez-moi
willem fond quand on constate que un
accusé comme salade et cela m'a été
applaudi à son arrivée à fleury mérogis
en dit long effectivement n'at-on pas la
crainte de voir ces nouveaux accusés
dans ce procès être accueillis comme des
héros comme des modèles en prison il est
bien évident qu'aujourd'hui les
personnes détenues qui sont incarcérées
pour des faits de terrorisme bénéficie
d'une aura au sein des établissements
pénitentiaires qui n'est plus à
démontrer maintenant c'est la raison
pour laquelle au niveau de l'ufap unsa
justice aujourd'hui nous demandons à
l'administration pénitentiaire et au
ministre de la justice de prendre en
main les choses et notamment de
respecter les engagements qui ont été
pris en 2018 lorsque l'ami d'israël
justice mais mme belloubet à l'époque
signe un relevé de conclusions dans
lequel s engager
créer 1500 places dédiées pour prendre
en charge ce type d'individu aujourd'hui
on en est à 450 places en me disant
qu'on va rester à 450 passe donc là
dessus c'est juste pas possible quand on
sait que grosso modo entre les individus
qui sont actuellement incarcérés pour
terrorisme c'est à dire un peu plus de
500 sans compter ceux qui sont dits
radicalisé mais non terroriste soit 1200
personnes
on en est en haut à plus de 1700 donc
1700 avec 450 places c'est juste pas
possible de pouvoir les gérer ensuite
derrière il est grand temps également
que l'administration pénitentiaire se
rendent compte que la prise en charge
qui elle propose aujourd'hui c'est à
dire des programmes dits de
déradicalisation ou des engagements de
la violence ne sert strictement à rien
et on va droit dans le mur avec ce genre
de choses
alors qu'elle devrait beaucoup plus se
concentrer sur des choses un peu plus
simple qui est d'empêcher la diffusion
de l'idéologie djihadiste au sein des
établissements
car aujourd'hui la véritable priorité
une urgence c'est celle là c'est comment
l'administration pénitentiaire prend les
moyens nécessaires pour empêcher la
diffusion ce type de ce type de message
au sein des tensions alors l'an du
procès en septembre dernier ali riza
paula lundi les principaux accusés un
qui a d'ailleurs été condamné ce soir à
30 ans de réclusion criminelle a fait
une déclaration un champion propose de
l'écouter quand je sortirai de prison
je ferai du banditisme encore plus je
vais faire pire ziya onomie quelle
réaction quand on sait d'ailleurs que ce
monsieur ce soir a fait appel ce qui va
ouvrir d'un meilleur la voie à un
nouveau procès quelle réaction quand on
entend ça mais c'est aussi compliqué
parce qu'enfin ce qu'il dit je vais
faire banditisme est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il va être comment il a dit encore
pire que ça du banditisme est encore
pire
oui en donc c'est vraiment la vraie
question c'est pour ça que c'est
important que lorsque ces personnes sont
condamnées
s'ils sont condamnés pour le terrorisme
l'ensemble des éléments d'infraction
soient reconstitués véritablement et pas
avoir ce sentiment que le confrère de la
défense a en dix ans
le dossier a été en fait bâclé on l'a
pris effectivement ce que le juge
d'instruction a décidé dans un premier
temps et on l'a coupé collé si c'est
bien ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
donc il faut absolument que la justice
prenne son temps pour donner ces
éléments là et pour éviter ensuite de ce
que disent au dessus en disant je vais
continuer de brahms liszt c'est un vrai
souci qui a été rappelée ci c'est un
vrai terroriste un vrai terroriste il
doit être traité d'une certaine façon il
peut pas être traités comme les gens qui
va pas apprendre les sondes au logis si
effectivement la personne a fait
exploser ou là à tirer sur des personnes
quand même 17 morts donc cette personne
ne va pas s'arrêter d'un coup
par contre je me dis ici une parle de
banditisme et de pierres ça voudrait
dire que ils disaient qu'ils n'avaient
pas participé à un acte de terroristes
et dans ce cadre là enfin c'est un vrai
c'est que les difficultés on sait très
bien que les personnes qui sont
condamnées même à 30 ans avec une peine
de sûreté des deux tiers
quand ils sortent le problème c'est pas
de rentrer c'est leur sortie et
là-dessus le personnel pénitentiaire
n'est pas pour la plupart alors ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure
450 personnes ne tenez pas là n'a pas
suffisamment d'encadrement n'a pas
connaissance pour pouvoir les traiter
donc je pense que là dessus c'est un
vrai problème que le terrorisme posent à
la société française et à notre justice
y compris la peine merci beaucoup à tous
les deux
viens oloumi wilfried faute d'avoir été
avec nous donc quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons de la grèce qui
va acheter 18 rafale est la france après
les tensions grandissantes avec la
turquie et puis nous parlerons du
printemps arable 17 décembre 2010 un
vendeur tunisien s'était immolé pour
protester contre ses conditions de vie
que reste-t-il aujourd'hui de ce
mouvement nous tenterons d'y répondre
[Musique]
tonique à recruter dans toutes les
couches de la société sans faire de tri
des mineurs des femmes des délinquants
des criminels de droit commun tout le
monde est venu à jaca en syrie il ya
encore quelques quelques années au
moment de charlie hebdo l'eau ou du
bataclan il y avait un état islamiste
qui semblait diriger tout ça la bascule
et se fait justement en 2015 et smith
est un peu le passage de relais d'al
qaïda l'état islamique quelque part dans
notre politique internationale vis bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre jihad et
de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france face à
la menace soit turc la grèce prend des
dispositions renforcées notamment son
armée de l'air objectif annoncé du
gouvernement grec qui avait dit dès
lundi soir l'achat de 18 rafale à la
france pour un coût total de 2,5
milliards d'euros
une vente qui va forcément affaiblir la
flotte aérienne française ce qui
inquiète les sénateurs david khalifa
une fierté tricolore mise au service des
autres 18 rafales sont appelés à
rejoindre l'armée grecque dont 6 dès
l'été 2021
une bonne nouvelle pour l'exportation
française est une nécessité pour la
grèce
dans un contexte de regain de tension
avec la turquie
le gouvernement hellénique a plus que
doublé ses dépenses en matière de
défense à 5,5 milliards d'euros malgré
la crise sanitaire actuelle le premier
ministre grec souhaite disposer de ses
avions de combat au plus vite la grèce
se trouve confronté à des circonstances
son précédent il y à beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur la fin de la crise
sanitaire actuelle mais le vaccin
marquera la fin de la pandémie et la
préface de l'air posco vide et le budget
est adaptée à ses conditions
et pour répondre à ces exigences
florence parly se rendra dès la semaine
prochaine à athènes afin de signer ce
contrat d'une valeur de 2 5 milliards
d'euros
une satisfaction pour les caisses de
l'état mais une inquiétude pour l'armée
de l'air française
sur les dix-huit rafale commandés si ce
sont 9 et 12 d'occasion sont prélevées
directement sur la flotte de 102
appareils
certains sénateurs s'inquiètent d'un
trou capacité à créer par cette vente
précipitée les capacités militaires
aériennes françaises pourraient s'en
trouver modifié voire affaibli
temporairement elle l'exécutif ne s'est
pas soucié des capacités opérationnelles
de l'armée de l'air dans cette affaire
l'avant des rafales à athènes ne relève
que d'une logique financière et de la
volonté de nourrir la vision politique
présidentielle d'une europe puissance
pour compenser cette perte les sénateurs
de la commission de la défense exige
donc que les recettes de la vente
reviennent automatiquement au ministère
des armées afin de financer l'équipement
de nouveaux avions de combat français
la grèce devient par ailleurs le premier
pays européen à se fournir en rafale une
transaction militaire qui devrait
ajouter de l'huile sur le feu dans les
relations diplomatiques déjà tendues
entre la turquie et la france
si la grèce appuyé sur la détente ou si
une nation comme la france ou les
etats-unis poussent les grecs à se
battre avec la turquie
ce sera la fin de l'otan c'est évident
parce que comment un membre de l'otan
peut-il attaqué un autre membre de
l'otan avec l'aide d'un autre membre de
l'otan
la vente de ces rafales pose question
sur la stratégie géopolitique adoptée
par emmanuel macron dans la résolution
du conflit méditerranéen ajouté installe
affaiblissement de la défense aérienne
française pointé du doigt par les
parlementaires
une stratégie court termiste financières
contre un raisonnement de défense
nationale à plus long terme entre
vendres et défendre il faut choisir
oui pour en parler nous sommes avec un
claude blanchet maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir fou
d'avenches maison merci d'être avec nous
alors question simple mais efficace
pourquoi la france dentelle des rafales
à la grèce d'abord la france est un
fournisseur traditionnel d'armement et
en particulier d'avions de chasse à la
grèce puisque depuis le milieu des
années 70 la grèce se fournir en mirage
en mirage 2000 est en effet en 75 après
l'invasion du nord de chypre par turk
par la turquie et bien la grèce a
commencé à acheter des mirages
récemment elle a demandé à aux
industriels français qui fabrique ces
mirages et et l'armement qui va avec de
les moderniser et la moitié de cette
flotte est en cours de modernisation
par ailleurs les f 16 américains que
possède également la grèce sont
également en cours de modernisation et
c'est dans ce cadre que la grèce
souhaite acheter
18 mirage 18,9 pardon et 10 10 10 dix
huit nouveaux avions français et dix
huit rafale et que en effet le
gouvernement français ne donnera son
accord a donné son accord et le contrat
devrait être signé la semaine prochaine
le second motif c'est comme l'a dit
votre sujet que en effet la france
souhaite contenir la turquie en
méditerranée
en général air méditerranée orientale en
particulier
il ya peut-être un troisième motif aussi
c'est de montrer que dans le fond les
états unis n'ont pas un monopole de
vente d'avions de chasse et que d'autres
pays comme la france peuvent aussi en
vendre c'est tout à fait conforme aux
règles de l'otan puisque l'otan ne
prévoit pas de monopole de vente des
états unis mais simplement une
interopérabilité et le rafale est
interopérable avec les autres avions de
l'otan alors cette transaction est ce qu
elle a fait vivre vraiment la force
aérienne française eh bien il va y avoir
en effet l'année prochaine à prélèvement
de 12 avions sur l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace française puisque c'est son
nouveau nom et qu' il ya donc deux
avions en moins ceci est prévu dit la
ministre de la défense française et
l'état major a l'air de considérer aussi
que cette baisse provisoire est limité
et n'empêchera pas l armée de l'air de
remplir ces trois missions la mission de
dissuasion nucléaire la mission de
surveillance de l'espace aérien français
et la mission d'opérations comme barca
nous comme d'autres au proche orient
pourquoi et bien parce que la moitié des
mirage 2000 français sont en voie
également de deux refus taz
d'amélioration et pour les mettre au
niveau des mirage 2000-5 mk2 et que par
conséquent ils sont aussi parfaitement
utilisable pour toutes ces missions
et puis il faut aussi faire de la place
dans l'est dans l'est dans les armées
dans l'armée de l'air pour pouvoir
accueillir les futurs avions qui sont en
préparation alors en effet pour le
moment
dassault qui fabrique ces avions a prévu
que 2019 2020 et 2021 toute sa
production serait consacré à
l'exportation pour assurer sa vocation
exportatrice et que à partir de 2020
2 eh bien on reprendra les fournitures à
l'armée de l'air et la loi d'orientation
militaire qui est une loi pluriannuelle
prévoit qu entre 2022 et 2024 et bien
chaque année l'armée de l'air achètera
l'état achètera pour l'armée de l'air
française
une dizaine de rafales du dernier modèle
donc il ya en effet pour l'année
prochaine cette situation que je viens
de décrire
mais avec une situation améliorée à
partir de 2022 2024
alors qu'est-ce qui explique comme dance
maison ces dernières années cette
demande croissante à l'exportation oui
alors c'est assez nouveau parce que dans
le fond ça date de 2015 2015 c'est le
qatar qui le premier achète 24 avions
rafale l'egypte quelques mois avant en
fait à peu près en même temps on avait
acheté également 24 le qatar a ensuite
demandé en ajouter 12 qui lui fait 36
avions rafale
et puis l'un d'eux en 2016 à acheter 36
avions rafale et 5 ont d'ailleurs été
livrés cd avions rafale neuf ont
d'ailleurs été livrés l'été dernier et
sont sur la base d'un banni dans le nord
ouest de l'inde d'autres pourparlers
sont en cours
l'indonésie à des pourparlers assez
avancé pour acheter également des
rafales alors pourquoi
et bien pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que on n'achète pas de
rafales sur catalogue ou dans un
showroom ou dans 1 1
à un show aérien les rafales ils sont en
opération
ils ont été en opération en libye ils
ont été en opération en syrie ils sont
en opération en afrique subsaharienne
dans le sahel et par conséquent tous les
militaires du monde entier peuvent voir
leur efficacité
ça c'est le premier motif évidemment le
plus important le deuxième motif c'est
qu' un certain nombre de pays ne veulent
pas mettre tous les oeufs dans le même
panier
ils veulent diversifier leurs
fournisseurs si le fournisseur principal
est américain eh bien la france joue un
rôle important comme élément de
diversification et troisième élément
évidemment la france forme les pilotes
des avions acheté des pays qui achètent
des avions rafale et des formes sur des
bases aériennes françaises
ensuite elle accompagne évidemment ces
avions en fournissant les pièces
détachées nécessaires et en assurant une
sorte de service après vente et de
coopération dans l'environnement de tout
ce qui concerne l'utilisation de ces
avions donc ça fait un ensemble de
raisons qui font que en effet
actuellement il ya une demande de rafale
dans le monde
évidemment ça fait pas toujours plaisir
aux concurrents quel qu'il soit mais
après tout c'est le jeu et que le
meilleur gagne
merci claude un blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales apaiser les
tensions c'était l'objectif de la
réunion qui s'est tenue ce mercredi
matin entre les signataires de l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien
l'iran qui ces dernières semaines a
durci sa position avec notamment
l'installation de trois nouvelles
cascades de centrifugeuses avancé
d'enrichissement d'uranium
ses interlocuteurs ont tenté de rappeler
téhéran à l'ordre dans la tente de
l'investiture de joe biden le vainqueur
de la présidentielle aux états unis qui
a confirmé sa volonté de revenir dans le
giron de l'accord de vienne françois
tisci reach les discussions ont duré
deux heures une réunion virtuelle en
raison de la pandémie de kobe de 19
objectif préserver l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien et des mines et les
tensions à la lumière des défis actuels
les participants ont discuté des travaux
en cours pour préserver l'accord d'ici
piot et et de la manière d'en assurer la
mise en oeuvre complète et efficace par
l'ensemble des parties un accord conclu
en 2015 à vienne en autriche mais mise à
mal depuis le retrait américain en mai
2018 et le rétablissement des sanctions
économiques par les états unis
un dossier iranien qui connaît depuis
fin novembre de nouveaux soubresauts
après l'assassinât d'un éminent
physicien nucléaire dans la foulée
téhéran avait décidé d'installer trois
nouvelles cascades de centrifugeuses
avancé d'enrichissement d'uranium
provoquant une profonde préoccupation de
la france du royaume uni et d'allemagne
pour téhéran
il n'est pas question de payer le prix
fort d'un respect de l'accord sans
obtenir en échange des avantages
économiques promis mais pour cette
question centrale
il faudra attendre l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche le 20 janvier
prochain
lui qui a confirmé sa volonté de revenir
dans le giron de l'accord de vienne le
président iranien hassan rohani
multiplient d'ailleurs les signaux
d'ouverture à l'attention de la
prochaine administration américaine et
se dit surtout très heureux du départ de
donald trump
certains disent vous êtes surexcités par
rapport à monsieur baden non nous ne le
sommes pas mais nous sommes très heureux
de voir trump partir un certain
enthousiasme tempéré par l'ayatollah ali
khamenei
ce mercredi le guide suprême iranien
déclaré devant des responsables que je
cite les inimitiés avec l'amérique ne
cesseront pas au départ de donald trump
le printemps arabe fête ses dix ans
demain ce mouvement de contestation
débuté après le geste symbolique d'un
revendeur tunisien le 17 décembre 2010
retour en images sur un soulèvement
populaire inédit à travers tout le monde
arabe
ce geste de désespoir face au
harcèlement policier libère la colère
d'une partie de la population tunisienne
un important mouvement de contestation
contre le pouvoir sans part du pays puis
se propage rapidement à l'étranger même
si la forme est l'intensité diffèrent
d'un pays à l'autre
une partie de la jeunesse de cette
région du monde se soulèvent pour
demander un changement de paradigme
politique
le printemps arabe a provoqué la chute
de quatre chefs d'état ou pouvoir depuis
plusieurs décennies
à commencer par zine el abidine ben ali
après 23 années au pouvoir il s'exile en
arabie saoudite où il meurt l'année
suivante au yémen les étudiants se
révoltent à la fin du mois de décembre
2010 face à la pression de la rue et de
l'opposition la communauté
internationale intervient pour faire
pression sur le président ali abdallah
saleh
un départ qui intervient 21 ans après
son arrivée au pouvoir à partir du 25
janvier 2011
d'importantes manifestations ont lieu en
egypte la violente répression par le
pouvoir aurait fait 840 morts
[Musique]
c'est la fin de 29 ans de domination
d'hosni moubarak
la répression violente des
manifestations en libye provoque un
soulèvement à l'est du pays
s'ensuit un conflit armé au cours duquel
la france les états unis le canada et le
royaume-uni interviennent et qui mène à
la chute et la mort de mouammar kadhafi
après 42 ans de règne et pour en parler
nous sommes avec kader abderrahim
chercheur à l'iris spécialiste du
maghreb ont soirée vers haïm merci
d'être avec nous dix ans après quel
bilan global si on devait le résumer en
quelques mots c'est difficile d'abord je
voulais juste préciser je ne suis plus à
layrisse médiateur de recherche allait
pse c'est difficile de résumer en
quelques mots une situation d'une telle
intensité et d'une telle importance pour
des peuples qui vont du maghreb
jusqu'aux pays du golfe mais je crois
que ce qui est le plus important à
retenir au delà des bilans c'est que
dans le fond les sociétés arabes se sont
réappropriés leur citoyenneté donc nous
sommes entrés dans un processus
et lorsque je disais il ya un instant
qu'il était beaucoup trop tôt pour faire
un bilan
c'est un c'est à cela que je faisais
allusion
le processus peut être long oui et je
peux comprendre notamment pour le cas de
la tunisie dont c'est l'anniversaire
demain de la révolte
je peux comprendre
qu'il y ait énormément de déception
d'autant que la situation économique et
sociale est absolument dramatique pour
pour la jeunesse de ce pays
effectivement parler de la tunisie on y
reviendra certainement mais aussi de
l'egypte de libye du yémen
tous ces pays qui ont pris des
trajectoires pour ainsi dire différentes
lequel d'entre eux se s'en sort le mieux
est lequel d'entre eux peut-être sans
semble le moins bien selon vous voilà là
vous me demandez voit encore une
question très difficile s'est dit qu'ils
ne pas faire de hiérarchie on veut pas
faire d une hiérarchie ou parce que
c'est c'est ce sont des sociétés à la
fois très différente la tunisie
ça n'est pas la libye la libye ça n'est
pas l'egypte et et c'est encore moins le
yémen donc je crois que ça dépend du
niveau d'éducation du niveau de
développement de toute une société d
élite évidemment intellectuels
universitaires artistique et lorsque
l'on à agréger
tout cela au sein d'une population on
met quand même beaucoup d'atouts de son
côté pour permettre à un pays de passer
d'un système politique à un autre qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les transitions pour
qu'elles se passent en douceur
malheureusement malheureusement c'est
vrai que dix ans après il n'y a pas eu
de résultats aussi probants et aussi
spectaculaire que ce que l'on attendait
en 2010 2011
quels sont selon vous les les
difficultés que l'on retrouve le plus
souvent justement sur le chemin de la
transition
invariablement je crois que c'est la
question économique on voit ces images
de ces de ces populations notamment en
tunisie qui brandissent ou en egypte la
selafa style je crois qui vous rend 10
du pain ça veut tout dire
et donc c'est vrai que les situations
sont très très disparates là aussi et
que si on ne parvient pas à stabiliser
la situation dans un premier temps sur
le plan économique
pour offrir des perspectives sociales
alors les évolutions les progrès sur le
plan institutionnel seront vains et
c'est ce que on observe notamment en
egypte c'est ce que l'on nous ment a vu
avec la tragédie syrienne et la guerre
civile en libye également
et puis la tunisie qui est toujours sur
le fil du rasoir et dont la situation
économique est dramatique et qui s'est
accentué avec la pandémie
puisque c'est un pays qui tirait
beaucoup de ces ressources du tourisme
est aujourd'hui comme vous le savez est
quasiment plus de tourisme en tunisie
voire quasiment nul et par conséquent sa
obère les perspectives de redressement
économique
est ce qu'on peut craindre un finalement
de nouveaux soulèvements peut-être
encore plus violent dans ce contexte que
vous nous décrivez si il y à des
soulèvements là je pense par exemple un
pays comme l'algérie
je crois que ça se fera autour des mêmes
questions et des leurs revendications
que celles qui sont nés en 2010 c'est à
dire cette réappropriation de la
citoyenneté
on veut participer à la vie publique au
voeu que notre voix compte
on veut participer à la vie politique
démocratique de ce pays est pas avoir
vous voyez bien où il avait pris quatre
les quatre exemples qui sont les plus
emblématiques dans le monde arabe la
tunisie l'egypte le yémen et la libye
à chaque fois ce sont minimum 20 ans de
pouvoir autocratique voire dictatorial
dans le cas de l'égypte ou de moammar
kadhafi sans partage et par conséquent
je crois qu'il faut on est à la fin d'un
cycle et qu'il faut que les populations
participent à la fois la définition et
aux choix et aux orientations de leur
pays aujourd'hui
d'une manière générale vous restez
optimiste justement sur la trajectoire
que vont suivre ces pays là même si vous
ne l'avez très bien décrit
la transition est souvent longue et
difficile et le contexte économique
n'aide pas oui oui je reste résolument
optimiste parce que je crois encore une
fois qu'il faut qu'on fasse l'éloge du
processus nous sommes dans ce processus
comme disent les anglo saxons 1
donc c'est en cours et je crois qu'il
faut observer à la fois ce qui va pas et
c'est légitime de le relever pour le
corriger
mais il faut aussi souligner que la
situation en 2000 en 7 pendant cette fin
d'année 2020 en tunisie notamment n'a
rien de comparable avec le pays dans
lequel les tunisiens vivaient jusqu'à
décembre 2010 c'est une véritable
démocratie l'état de droit est en
construction
et je crois que c'est un pays qui
dispose de tous les atouts d'une élite
suffisamment formés et éclairé pour
renforcer ces évolutions et parvenir à
faire réussir cette transition
démocratique merci beaucoup khadr dès
rahim chercheurs dont calypso et non pas
lire ils sont à corriger pour l'avenir
merci à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité comme à chaque fin d'année
venir quand il donnera demain une
conférence de presse l'objectif de ce
rendez vous annuel répond aux
préoccupations de la population cette
année le format de cette conférence sera
largement revu et ce pour diverses
raisons les explications avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine cléroux
la grande conférence de presse de ce
jeudi 17 décembre sera différente des
précédentes
à bien des égards pour commencer
vladimir poutine ne sera pas présent
physiquement dans la même salle que les
journalistes comme c'est le cas
d'habitude l'événement aura lieu en
visioconférence le président russe
restant dans sa résidence en banlieue de
moscou
d'autre part cette année il n'y a pas eu
de ligne directe avec vladimir poutine
cet événement où tout à chacun peut
poser une question directement au
président sur des problématiques divers
conséquence la conférence de presse de
ce jeudi comprendra aussi des questions
de simples citoyens un format inhabituel
donc les avec le même objectif répondre
aux préoccupations de la population
au premier rang desquels la situation
sanitaire lié à la cobi 19 bien sûr mais
aussi le logement ou encore le soutien
aux familles l'actualité internationale
devrait également être évoquée par
certains des journalistes comme par
exemple les relations avec les états
unis ou encore la sphère navalni les
sujets de discussions sont donc
multiples on l'aura compris mais
vladimir poutine prend le temps d'en
aborder un maximum l'année dernière
l'exercice avait duré plus de quatre
heures et 15 minutes le temps de
répondre à 71 question c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve dans quelques instants pour
un point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]